foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
yo what's up everybody
what's going on Happy Friday thank you
for joining me
we're gonna be doing some drawing today
some 2D art I'm very excited to dive
into it with you guys my renders come
along uh quite well I'm really happy
with how it's turned out we'll get to it
in a second
um yeah I'm excited to just chill and
work with you guys for the next couple
hours here we're gonna go to about like
two hours and so
um but what's up everybody see you all
in the chat what's up 10 um good to see
you
yeah sweet
what's up Ronan
yeah and absolutely we got soda Monte
running the stream as well so shout outs
to you guys
um
all right
before we hop into it I have some
announcements for y'all first off there
is a submission link it's live the link
is in the description
um and just because there's a submission
link does not mean you have to submit
that's the most important thing right
um please take the time that you guys
have uh to make your art as good as you
can make it have fun with it you do not
need to submit just because there's a
submission link all right that
submission link is in the description of
this video it's also on the get started
page on the Discord uh if you guys are
not part of the Discord server please
head on over join it I got that link
below for you as well it's a really fun
it's a big old community of passionate
positive artists that are helping each
other out
um especially during this month-long
challenge that we're doing through
August and when we're not doing these
we're doing weekly challenges and a
bunch of fun stuff like that so
definitely head on over to the Discord
it's there to help you guys out so
that's announcement number one and
that's my number two look what I got
right here what is this what is this
what could this possibly be
this is
boss fight stickers look at this look at
this these are designed by my buddy Gabe
peregrino
um and they're freaking awesome I gave
you like a really nice assortment of
stickers here
um you guys can you have to worry about
uh you know stick them on just one thing
you can get them on a few things here so
um you know these can go on the back of
your phone whatever go on your helmet if
you're into like skateboarding or
whatnot
um but I'm really happy with how these
turned out so definitely pick some up
they're Linked In the description down
below uh goes to my website my print
store noisegrainandlight.com there's
also endless engine stickers from the
last challenge we did and a bunch of
other like
um photography prints that I've made in
the past so definitely check that out
get you some stickers it helps support
the challenge
um I know it might be a little pricey
um you know for a sticker sheet I try to
keep it as as reasonable as I could
um the company that also makes them they
got a there's a pretty large overhead
for them to make the stickers too
um so uh anyway just go check them out
they're super fun get you some challenge
to swag while you're doing these
challenges
um anything else
any other shout outs got a shout out to
sponsors
um lots of awesome prizes this time
around so Rococo
um they're they're back they're always
they're always supporting these
challenges they have Rococo video which
is a no suit needed motion capture
solution for you guys and it's going to
help you out on your projects here
especially for this challenge link also
in the description down below uh for
Coco video go check that out
um we have Kit bash 3D as well uh
hooking you guys up with some assets we
got uh embergen over at Jenga FX
amberjen is free for the month for you
guys who want to use that and then we
also have caft who is a uh like a a
really cool Turkish design company and
they got like a bunch of sweet shirts
and whatnot they're giving out top 100
shirts to all the top 100 artists
um and first through fifth place of
course as well
um but just want to shout out the
sponsors and I think
it's time
to get into it
all right y'all
guy Collins what's going on
what is going on
you've prepared a 2 000 word essay about
my render wall speaking of my render let
me uh pull it up for you and and
actually here's what we're gonna do I'm
going to show you this first
so we have
um
nothing on my screen let me let me get
this going
boom all right this is what we um what
we had last week we started with this
last week my goal here is obviously to
do this all in like some crazy 2D style
um and
that's what we have now yeah this is
what we have right now
um I filled out the entire background I
added like the little Sumo portrait up
here the scaffolding
um all the people are animated and stuff
there's some railing like it did some
detail now what I want to do on the
stream today with you guys
um let's just Loop this guy what I want
to do on the stream today is a few
things we'll see how far I can get with
it but basically we have the ring right
here right I want to draw out this ring
um and block it out just a little bit
further draw it out and
um do a few different angles of it so I
can actually look like it's 3D like
we're orbiting around this thing so I'm
gonna do that
um and then I'm going to what the heck
it's like playlist thing and then I'm
basically gonna start drawing some
people in the foreground off to the
sides behind the ring as well just to
surround this entire ring with people so
we're gonna do a lot of drawing today
which I'm excited about because I love
drawing it's a blast
all right
let us let us begin first with a little
bit more detail on this ring on the
blockout now it looks like the angle we
have we're actually not seeing the steps
of the Ring which I'm kind of bummed
about but you know it's uh it's all good
I suppose
okay so let's uh let's block out this
ring a little bit more I have a drawing
that I'll show you guys that I put
together actually let me bring it in
and I'll show you what we're gonna do
let's see here let's see here where did
I save that to
[Music]
you can see where I'm pulling this up
all right I gotta pull it I have a I
have a few drawings that I did this
morning
that I want to show you guys
he's going
[Music]
oh here we go okay all right
apologies bear with me
so here's a reference sheet
of all the stuff that I'm referencing
here
F by the way the program called puref
and it's totally free it's great
all right here we go here we go
boom all right so I just did some quick
sketches of the Ring to kind of get a
sense of the shape of it this is a
little salt basket we're gonna block
that out real quick
um this is kind of like the straw that
outlines this ring the steps the straw
on the steps so this is just giving me
an idea of what this looks like
um we're gonna block that out very
quickly it'd be cool to do like a little
broom I'll probably just draw the broom
inside of Photoshop there's this bucket
which I'm gonna block out as well and uh
and draw that as well right so we're
going to get a few assets we're gonna
block them out then we're gonna draw
them and then once we have the ring
drawn a few times and get it animated in
then we'll go with like the people try
and get some people like this or
something so that's a
that's what we're going to do today
let's let's start with it so first off
let's get this ring going all right so
the easiest way to do this I'll probably
start with a circle spline
hit R for rotation hold shift to snap it
on the
different angles there and let's make
another Circle spline this is going to
be the thickness t for scale scale that
down
right and then I'm going to select both
of those hold Ctrl Alt
and I'll select a little sweep
modifier here
and that second Circle spline
is our thickness right and I'm hitting t
for scale just to scale that up and down
it doesn't matter where it is in 3D
space
it just knows when you have two splines
in a sweep
right it gets you set up easy right okay
let's scale this one up
get that ring going nice and
looking at our reference here it looks
like
we have
that middle area like we have here okay
boom
and it's broken up
into
a couple little pieces so I'm gonna
Center this first and foremost
go ahead and scale this thickness down
[Music]
something like this
and just have it sit halfway in the
ground which I think by default
there we go something like that boom and
then let's go ahead and copy this
hit C to make it editable so now we can
actually start
moving some polygons around and I want
to select these two guys
maybe these four I don't know maybe
these two
these two and these two and I'm gonna
hit UI to invert the selection and in
fact I think what I'll do is hit up and
that is break essentially it breaks it
up that's the way I memorize all my
hotkeys up spells up and I'm gonna break
it up so it's gonna split the geometry
into two pieces what we had selected and
what we didn't have selected right
let's go ahead and hide that sweep
and
we will
scale this down
and we do want to make sure we delete
the geometry
that we uh that we don't need there
good
hide that guy so this is kind of
basically what the ring looks like
something like that wonderful and then
we have a few like outside ones as well
that I want to block in
so what's the best way
to do this I'll probably just start with
a cylinder
rotate it
rotate it 90 holding shift and uh let's
bring this guy out
and we can actually reference
this sweep here
the thickness or the size of this circle
spline
right and it looks like it's 2.1832
centimeters and I'm just going to put
that into the radius of this uh
didn't work why doesn't that work is it
times two let's try so you can do that
number
times two
and maybe that's right
that doesn't look right
I don't know why
anyway we'll eyeball it
get it in there halfway
that should just be fine right cool
let's get that to the edge
bring it in just a touch
control drag it over to copy it select
both of those with shift
R for rotation control drag holding
shift to snap it right so Snaps are not
90.
perfect
we can take all of these and kind of
make a little bit more room because I
want to put a cylinder right up in there
too so
let's just bring the height down on all
these guys
and I'm actually gonna
Ctrl C control V these guys R for
rotation and I'm going to get these
going on at 45.
let's get that top view real quick
[Music]
just kind of bring all these guys out
nice select those top four
bring the bring the height down
and then just kind of
guide them into place
nice okay
and we can hide the sweep there boom now
from camera view this looks like looks
like that all right
so next thing I want to do let's make a
bucket
um and a little salt basket
and I'm just going to do that in a new
project file
it's going to be a lot easier so what
we'll do is make a cylinder I'm also
going to make a person
for scale to know how big this this
bucket is I'm gonna scale it down here
let me say our bucket can be about this
big
it up
and this is just a block out this is
just so that we can like draw it in the
reference I'm gonna make it editable and
this is going off of like this kind of
style bucket right
so
let's go ahead and actually get rid of
these horizontal lines and we already
made it editable yes of course we can
undo it
you know and get rid of those height
segments that's one way to do it another
way to do it
let's say we we can't go back make it
editable how the heck we're going to do
that so
UL is a loop selection you can go to
select and find where is it Loop
selection
UL that's your shortcut
one two three holding shift and then we
want to dissolve these and I believe m n
is the shortcut but if you go up in here
dissolve yep
boom you can also control delete does
the same thing
that way when we scale up this uh these
top faces and I'm gonna do UL again for
a ring selection or a loop selection
rather
t for scale and we'll just scale it up a
little bit just like this
this is the the general shape of our
bucket MW is gonna uh inset this so we
can always right click all this stuff is
from just a right click and it's in set
right m w or I think I is also shortcuts
are kind of weird in cinema not gonna
lie
uh d
is going to be our extrude tool or we
can just control drag this down
and scale it down
right so we have our bucket shape
awesome awesome awesome
okay so from here we're going to make a
couple cuts so KL is a loop cut or Loop
slash path cut
and I believe that is again
accessed from this menu here if you
right click Loop path cut these are all
your cut options
and let's go into a side view
and I'll make let's see
we'll make one
two
three just eyeballing it uh we'll go
back to our faces UL we'll grab these
guys
holding shift to get all that and then
I'm gonna hit
D for extrude
and just kind of move that out a little
bit
that's the idea right
now actually before I do that before I
do that I'm gonna grab
this bit here
I'm gonna grab other side
this guy holding shift
then we'll hit d
ude that out
awesome
select all these
I don't want to extrude that
[Music]
foreign
yes I could probably do this with
symmetry
I'm just lazy which sounds ridiculous
let me hit D again
those go in
and like technically these should come
in a little bit more
ah we don't need to be so precise with
it
[Music]
because we're just using this for a
drawing but
what the heck I'm a perfectionist I
waste a lot of time doing this I'm gonna
hit T and just scale them
let's see here scale them
I should probably rotate the whole thing
there we go so they all scale uniformly
back to the line
and they can all just come in
just a little bit like that cool great
little bucket set up
um this technically keeps going so
let me grab that let me grab that hit d
come up with it check our reference yep
just comes up a touch
foreign
and then I want to make like a little
Arc here and the easiest way what's
these there's so many ways but what's
the easiest way
um
[Music]
I guess I'll just do it with a spline
we can hide the figure we can delete
them actually I don't really need them
anymore
all right let's go to the point mode
grab the spline
boom boom
I'll just make a point there
point there
that Clint what the heck that looks
horrible
well I yeah I agree I'm gonna grab all
these make them hard interpolation so
there's no like
small little bezier curves that are
going to screw this up I'm gonna grab
these and I'm just gonna um chamfer them
let's see chamfer boom
something like that
yeah that's fine
I'll grab that spline and then we're
gonna hold alt and we're going to pop
them into an extrude and by holding alt
what that does is makes what you have
selected in an automatic child of what
you are selecting all right so if I
didn't hold Alt
it would just spawn this extrude I
forgot I could mix up modifier well
maybe it's a modifier
I feel like these are modified anyway
then you drop the spline into the
extrude by holding alt on the spline you
just kind of like
skip a step
in the extrude let's go ahead and bring
that down like this
great great
Center it
and I'm actually gonna go a step further
and like
bring these at these spline handles out
just a little bit so they kind of Pop
out pop out from this thing
boom
[Music]
like that wonderful wonderful
and finally just a little
work on the shape here let's bring that
down
kind of take I didn't even save this
we're living on the edge I'm gonna take
all this alt G for group
and I'm just gonna work the shape of it
a touch
reference
the actual reference right here this guy
so it's a little bit like shorter and
wider
right
we got this guy here too
these handles go way up
again this is pure ref
pure reference pure ref
all right it looks like there's only two
on that two like rings on that thing so
let's uh
you know what I don't even have to draw
the second ring I'll just leave it as is
be like it'll just be easier that way
all right let's bring these guys up a
little bit more
and out
and same for the handle
bring it up
cool
L will actually let you move your axis
and that feels a little bit better to me
I think we're good with this and it will
help us draw this
um in Photoshop all right so let's just
call this bucket
and copy it over to our block out scene
come on now what the heck copy
paste
there we go and since we used uh a
figure as like a scale reference we
actually
have this bucket the correct size right
so we can move this wherever we want
we'll come back we'll get that going
right
um let's go back into that scene I can
go ahead and delete this and then
[Music]
time for some tea
and yeah
um this is a standing desk I love this
thing I don't even know what brand it is
not that it matters or anything I bought
it from a friend second hand and uh I
have one of these like draft chairs that
are super tall so I'm sitting but I can
also stand if I want to as well it's
really nice having the standing desk is
really nice for uh
you know I guess for health you can
stand up pace around
[Music]
especially for us artists too you know
because we're uh we're in the chair a
lot we're at the computer a lot that's
for sure
this tea is some black tea
um
my buddy got it for me from China as a
gift and I don't even know what it is I
can't even read the label
but uh it's some good black tea
yeah I don't even know if you can guess
if you can see this
hmm no that's just a dark pit
um moving on okay
let's make a salt basket
let's bring out a little a little friend
here
[Music]
and we'll bring out a cube this one's
gonna be easy t for scale
this mug down
bring them up scoot them over
C to make it editable
right it's so tiny but you can see how
it goes from a cube if I hit C it goes
to a little
little uh polygon here we'll go to our
face mode grab that move it down just a
bit that's probably the shape of our
salt basket
right this little guy we're going for
this guy right here
this one's so easy
um we're gonna inset this so m w is the
inset tool
we'll get that just like that it's
pretty thin and um so we can move this
like this right
or if we hold Ctrl it'll actually
give us some new geometry so I'm just
gonna do that boom salt basket and then
what we'll do is bevel this thing
so what you can do
um
let's grab the cube
let's drop a bevel I think these are
modifiers drop a bevel modifier into it
and we're beveling everything
we don't want to Bevel everything we
just want to Bevel a certain part of it
so we're gonna actually mess with this
little selection option right here and
in the cube let's go ahead and just grab
the
the uh the edges that we want to Bevel
so the outer edges we want to Bevel
right pretty much everything except
so here I'll do that alt Ctrl a we'll
select it all
and I don't want to Bevel
these rings around the top and I don't
want to Bevel
these little guys right up here and I
think
that's gonna be everything so we have
all these selected right we go up to
select and we can
store selection right here boom
[Music]
we go to the bevel we grab that little
selection tag drop it in there and that
looks horrible so what
what the heck maybe what we gotta do
is get better
at 3D
come on Clint what the heck man
this is where this is where you guys see
me fail pretty hard all right
do I grab these I don't know
probably not let's go to the selection
and we'll go update the selection
dude that looks so bad
I'm gonna do it the horrible way and uh
what on Earth dude
it's because that's selected
It's gotta be right
did I just did I have it right from the
beginning
why
gross gross guys well here look I ain't
got the time I am going to
so like both of these
and we are going to connect objects plus
delete all right so we got this ugly
thing
UL for the loop selection that's not
going to do it
I'm just going to grab this Geo and
delete it it's horrible
it's horrible it's horrible it's all
just so disgusting and I'm sure there
this is the worst way to oh do I know
why
maybe I know why
because I didn't get
get this one
update that selection let's give myself
some credit dang it
uh
what on Earth you select all this you oh
all right so edges 28 hit uo it's gonna
like optimize that's the shortcut for
optimize right click it's in here
somewhere there it is Boom optimize
and yeah it looks like okay let's try
with points we have 16 points you owe
optimize it's going to basically combine
any points that are really close to each
other and that's not working
it's just so annoying
hmm
all edges except the corners
but Norm man if I was good that's the
thing if I was good
at this game
I would be winning right now
but you know
when you live stream
sometimes you just you know sometimes
this happens
dude why how many edges do I miss
this is brutal y'all this is freaking
brutal I'm just hoping
that one of these attempts
like this one
okay update
and it still doesn't work
foreign
absolute Darkness
okay
okay all right
um Bridge tool what's the bridge tool
let's get the line out
and I'm only gonna do this
let's be smart
let's cut this down the middle
this way let's cut it this way
let's grab these
points here
delete all that
cut there make a cut there
like by the time it takes me
within the time it takes me to set up
symmetry
so basically be finished could have been
done by now let's see
um
I hit L I want to move this Anchor Point
to the middle of this thing right and
the best way let's see if this works
um the Axis Center tool I want to move
the axis
to the furthest Z and the
for this negative X
and that looks like it's right there
where we want it
execute and when I
I don't really care about the Y but hey
let's do it y can go bottom y execute
bam now when I zero this out reset
transformation it's right there in the
middle I'll select it holding alt let's
get a little
symmetry on it
and can you do times four symmetry
I don't know
I feel like you should be able to
apparently
you can't I don't know maybe you can
I'll just do it again
I don't care
watch me do it boom all right done all
right so now I'll just link all this
stuff up
um
go to Edge mode
Bridge tool what is the bridge tool
where you at m b
and uh
dude why
what
hide all this
get rid of our friend here
how is this not
important
not important
is that basket guys wow
can't win them all
copy this thing taste this thing
foreign
is good enough
all right that's our little salt basket
it'll be up in here somewhere
um the broom I will do just in Photoshop
as we draw it out right
so let's make sure this is sitting on
the ground
make sure our bucket is sitting on the
ground
awesome
we got our ring looking nice
all right so this bucket
I'm just gonna bake this all down
[Music]
Ram same for the basket
bam okay
there we go
salt going probably here in the corner
technically this bucket is like
on the ground let's get that Access
Center tool drop the Y all the way to
the bottom
let's get this water bucket in the
corner here
scale it up
for the sake of the render I'm just
going to get it
up in the ring I know it's not accurate
but hey
going for art not
historical accuracy here
so all right let's get this cute little
salt bucket rotated
something like that cool
I don't really mind that it's clipping
that's okay
let me get our Assets in there okay
great so let's see we want to pull a
couple of these frames as a reference
I'm going to get rid of the characters
holding alt I'm just going to click
these little stopwatches once twice
all right I guess they're not
stopwatches they're like little circles
boom
all right
so here's what I'll do I need a
reference frame for the center
I'm actually going to hide the bucket in
the cube or in the basket for now let's
find that middle frame
somewhere right here
and this is such a small reference
such a tiny little thing we're drawing
but
you know
that's what we're doing
so I'm just gonna grab that
we'll go into Photoshop
and let's go ahead and make a new
a new layer here or a new file and this
will be 30 40 by 2160
foreign
this in and scale it up
all right
all right so that's what we're working
on I also want to grab a couple angles
of uh because it's 3D obviously right so
I'm going to write this down this is
frame 46 that we're on
in case I need to come back to this
so that's 46 and then let's grab
a zero frame zero we'll grab
and then maybe
one in between like here or something
let's see
frame four
frame three
yeah we'll grab frame three as well
sweet all right so here comes frame
three
and frame zero
[Music]
all right cool
I guess uh I guess it doesn't really
matter which one I start with um I guess
the last thing too I do want to double
check
I might cheat the ring forward a little
bit
like to me that just feels better
even though it's technically like not
correct it just feels a little bit
better
and I think I'm gonna go with that
[Music]
once we get set up here I'll hop in with
you guys and
hang out for a little bit
that's the frame we want right there
boom
reference frame cool
we'll have three
zero
[Music]
foreign
so I have never animated anything in my
life in terms of uh like 2D animation so
probably better ways to go about this
but I'm having a good time with it and I
think that's all that really matters
how you guys doing
um kind of with a show of hands who's
working on their art
today
I know you guys are
that's why we're here you know hanging
out working on our art together
ah how's it been too by the way with
this challenge like a lot of you have
done these before
um
is this one different in any way I'm
curious to hear how you guys are doing
uh in the challenge
if you need any sort of support if you
have anything you're stuck on
we can chat here for just like a little
bit and then I'm gonna hop back into the
art
we also do these like Monday meetups on
Discord throughout the challenge so
every Monday so coming Monday
I'll be on the Discord server with you
guys
um and some of the moderators as well
we'll be bringing you onto the stage and
just chatting for five minutes about
your art
yes we have a lot of people in the chat
working on their art right now that's
what's up yeah
character animator yeah that's what I'm
actually gonna use for the actual
characters
yeah
uh Frankie is okay to use two of the
camera views and transition between them
for the challenge I think that would be
some outside of the box thinking I'm
down for it if you can make it work go
for it see what you can do
yeah scouty all right um definitely yeah
I love environments as well that's kind
of what I'm used to doing
um so I'm I feel like I'm being pushed
as well during this thing
do I live do I live in Japan no I wish I
did my God that'd be cool
now this is this is uh this stuff here
this and this was actually here at this
house
um
before I even got here which is crazy I
love it
[Music]
tomek all right so you said uh you're
doing well so far and uh you need a
constant influx of inspiration though I
know what you mean you gotta feel like
you're uh you're making something cool
along the way
um
and you're worried about the polishing
stage
you know I'd keep keep going keep having
fun as long as you're enjoying what
you're doing I think you're gonna be in
a good place for sure
um and as long as you can get to
something that is deliverable at the end
of the day
I guess that matters too
yeah sweet tomek I'm glad you enjoyed
the kip bash stuff Fabricio what up dude
first place endless engines in the house
what's up man
you're having fun as well heck yeah
out of curiosity how much time do I
spend on my piece of art every day
that's a good question
um
honestly not much it's probably in the
like hour and a half to two hours max
per day that I spend on this
um
I'd like to spend more
I should probably allocate some more
time uh this upcoming week I would love
to do that so
yeah
thank you
when do you tell yourself that you're
done and you're ready to render that's
um that's a tough one that's kind of on
you to the side of course but
um
that's kind of what the community is for
or other artists it are for you can show
them your work get some feedback and
feel you know kind of you don't have to
do what they say certainly not
but it could be a good like barometer of
where you're at and you can weigh their
opinions about your art and decide
whether or not you feel
strongly enough to implement their
um their notes right
sweet okay yeah this challenge is the
fastest you've ever done any of these
um in a good way yeah no it's great uh
we all get faster the more we do it
especially if you're working on a
certain style certain workflow the more
you do it the quicker you'll be so
that's good to hear
what editing software should I use after
rendering all my frames like color
grading motion blur Etc
um what's up wed how you doing man so I
would use
um DaVinci Resolve just because it's
free and it's made for color grading
it's a fantastic software there's lots
of tutorials for it
um the layout is really nice and pretty
easy to understand they kind of separate
everything in sections at the bottom of
the screen
so definitely Da Vinci I would look into
Da Vinci for that yeah
I know this month is flying by huh
[Music]
block out to next phase all right how do
you do that RDX so
depending on if you're blocking out with
like how I was modeling just now like
real rudimentary shapes
um I would start looking for those
assets
um or if their assets you're kind of
blocking out with assets
and that helps you skip a step but I
mean there's many ways like a block out
let's just let's say you're just doing
like um I watched this vending machine
tutorial in blender with the grease
pencil great tutorial and um he started
out with a blockout which was literally
just a cube or a rectangle he found his
camera angle
um and he added some little feedies to
it he added a couple insets and just
generally blocked it out he sketched it
out in 3D now how does he go from that
to the final
um definitely check out that tutorial if
you can find it it's called um like 2D
to 3D
process grease pencil and blender it's a
vending machine like on like a you know
kind of a little rocky grassy ground
thing
um
super cool super super cool tutorial
and you watch him do it you watch him go
from from block out uh to final and it's
just adding more detail to your geometry
that's it really texturing
um all that good stuff so
um that's it we're talking
hand modeling right of course there's
assets out there right so a lot of
people will just block out with the
final assets
um or my stage here it's like you're you
know I have this stage but if I wanted
to
you know keep going with it in my case
that's going to be a 2d drawing I'm
using the 3D block out as reference for
my 2D drawing and I'm just drawing over
top of that block out and adding more
detail to it so it's it's kind of more
of a question of like what details do
you want to add to your art
um
and you can just infinitely keep adding
details it's crazy very fun
all right guys I think I think I'm gonna
hop in let's get drawing yeah let's do
it
all right so I want to do
the most evil thing I can possibly do
um
I will first off save my project file
not as
come on now come on now yes on my
computer
foreign
and
um
we'll see how that goes
and it takes a minute to like enable for
some weird reason
Windows ink
there it is
[Music]
now I have pen pressure going amazing
all right
brush tool I'm using this uh little
pencil brush that I downloaded
from some YouTube tutorial
it's all set up here it's got pen
pressure for this transfer pen pressure
for the shape Dynamics it's got some
scattering and texture to make it look
like a pencil
right and I'm just gonna get up in here
let's go ahead and uh drop the opacity
of all these guys
so we can see what we're doing let's
take this guy and make it
black is that going to be easier to see
control I
it's easier on the folks
watching this from their bed
at night time
that's who's easier for
okay
let's start with this one
[Music]
and that's nearly invisible my goodness
sorry folks in bed
we're going like we're doing this all
right okay
so we'll trace this first one
hold shift here is going to help us
get that real straight line
nice
nice nice nice okay so these guys are
like uh little straw pieces
so
kind of looking like
[Music]
a little straw guys just chilling
wonderful
boom just like that
same deal
all the way back
all the way
to the end
amazing
amazing amazing amazing amazing amazing
I love it already it's looking sweet
get
when's the due date
the due date wins the due date the dude
is on
can anyone answer
our friend's question
curious if you all know does anyone know
the due date
[Music]
no no one yet it's August 27th y'all 11
59 PM PST
thanks
well you know what's crazy though is I
have to like remember how many lines I'm
drawing no I don't
because
the difference between
this View and the other view is pretty
large
foreign
[Music]
there we go
sweet
and we'll just give this
a little bit of detail and texture here
[Music]
awesome fantastic
now if I'm being smart about this and I
should be
I would like to
use symmetry
for this so we'll get there
ah there's got to be a way to set up
symmetry in Photoshop
I know there is I know there is but I
don't know how to do it
all right let's get
[Music]
let's get
foreign
this would be the ring
[Music]
wonderful I don't need to add too much
detail of that just because I don't want
to muddy it up
[Music]
well
awesome so I can trace all day long it's
hard to do this for memory though
all right so go to the butterfly and
select What type oh
hey
look at that
[Music]
wonderful wonderful wonderful
I love it
[Music]
so if I drew if I do this will that be
perfectly aligned with this one
oh
[Music]
it won't be
so I'll have to do it the
manual way in terms of the manual
symmetry way
which won't be too bad
I don't understand the shape of this
okay
um
and we'll get this guy going around
I'm just gonna like not worry too much
about
oh
[Music]
I think it's fine I'm not gonna worry
too much about the detail on the back
side
because I think
[Music]
the less
detailed things get further away they
are right
[Music]
I think that works I think that works
cool
same for this guy back here
wonderful and yeah I know I said I'll do
the Symmetry but
[Music]
foreign
okay I think that's uh
pretty much it for
there we go
yeah
sweet
sweet sweet okay
so that's one down
shall we add some shading let's try it
but I'll do it in a separate layer
[Music]
foreign
a little bit as well
sweet all right
it's good looks good looks good I'm
happy with that
as a sketch I think going back in and
adding doing some like really nice line
art is what I'll have to do but I I want
to start with this sketch and see what
it's going to look like when we animate
it right so we're gonna do that here
um once we have these other three we'll
see how it feels right
so that's um
see
shading
all right let's move on to the next the
next angle
now these two I feel like I need to
match the
specific
[Music]
amount of like little straw pieces I'm
drawing
maybe I don't but since they're so close
to to each other
in terms of when they're animated who
knows I will figure it out together
[Music]
which one is uh
all right so technically it's this one
all right
[Music]
thank you
and I'm just giving myself a little bit
more of a
it's hard it's just hard to see
here we go
foreign
[Music]
cool
sweet so
you guys are asking what the heck I'm
doing so basically
um
let's back all the way up
this is my art that I'm working on
right so I'm trying to go for a 2d
animated style
um I hand drew the background and last
stream last week
we made a like an animated crowd system
and I populated it with a handful of
like hand-drawn crowd people that I then
used after effects to populate this
background image with and I wrapped that
around a plane or I wrapped a plane
around the camera
um so when we're moving in 3D space it
actually looks like it's scrolling by
right so that's what I'm doing I'm
trying to mess with the new Styles this
time 2D Style
um and really it just comes down to me
doing a lot of drawing which is exactly
what I wanted to do this time because uh
you know it's fun to try new stuff right
so what I'm doing now is actually hand
drawing the like the the ring right and
I'm doing it in three pictures because
uh or three drawings rather because we
can see that we're orbiting in 3D and I
want it to look like it's actually
orbiting right so once I get these two
other drawings done I'm going to go in
After Effects and animate it and see if
I can get it to feel like it's actually
a 3D camera move and then I'll pop that
in into the final render here and we'll
see what it looks like so that's what
I'm doing I'm using c4d to actually
block out my scene and I'm render using
these little renders here as uh as a
reference for me inside of Photoshop
right so I have this
c4d render going and I'm using it to
trace
this background
and that's where we're at that's what
we're doing today
[Music]
foreign
feels nice to me
I had the weirdest dream last night
so
I dreamed that I was
doing a video with Tim and Eric
and uh if you guys don't know Tim and
Eric there's like really weird I don't
even know if sketch is the right word
they're just some weird comedy dudes
really funny and um
I was in like
Tim's office or Eric's office
and the other guy was like in a meeting
behind closed doors I was like what the
heck
and they were like yeah you know I know
it's six o'clock I know you should
technically be going home
but you need to hang on just a little
bit because Eric or Tim yet whatever the
other guy was
he's in this meeting and he's meeting
with some Executives and you just gotta
wait for him and I was like okay
and like
an hour and a half went by and he still
wasn't out I was like what the heck and
like one of the guys the guy who was I
was like in his waiting room he was
chill and he was like
he like he was like man I got cancer I
was like oh God that's horrible dude
that's rough
and um
and then like
hour and a half goes by I finally opened
the office door
to the other guy to Eric or to Tim
and I go in there and he's it feels like
a um
like uh like what is that like Pro Bass
it feels like a pro bass fishing shop
it's like all done up with like guns on
the wall like hunting rifles on the wall
like deer heads and stuff I'm like
that's so odd like why would you do your
office like that and it was huge too it
was like massive
and like
I just remember being so mad I was like
I waited a uh an hour and a half and I'm
supposed to be at home with my wife
having dinner
what the heck what's taking so long I'm
out so you guys are so selfish and
unprofessional
dub
I just remember like taking off and that
was my dream I don't know
I don't know what the heck that was or
what that came from but uh yeah that was
my random Tim and Eric dream
we're at this point guys we're talking
about random dreams
[Music]
because this this art is taking a minute
you know but it's cool we're hanging out
we're chilling
I think the craziest dream I ever had
was when
I was a kid and I had this dream like no
joke I had this dream I I swore it was
like
30 times
and I've only had recurring dreams like
three times in my life I'll tell you all
three of them so the first one was the
Crete definitely the creepiest
um it was I grew up in Florida
and I moved that I moved out of Florida
when I was six all right so it wasn't
there long I was just there for my
childhood but the very early parts of my
childhood
on the beginnings right and
I had this dream we live in this
one-story house
and
in the dream I woke up
as a little kid
in my bedroom lights were off you know
as you would if you actually woke up at
night
and
I noticed that underneath my door
I saw a sliver of light I was like huh
who is up at this hour
so I get out of bed
I walk over to my door
I crack it open and the living room
lights are on I'm like okay that's weird
and I hear someone wrapping presents
because I maybe it was Christmas at the
time or something
and we had our Christmas tree up right
so yeah definitely Christmas time
wrapping presents this late at night
seems right you know you want to wrap
the presents uh while the kids are
sleeping
makes sense so I walk out
and let me make sure I'm getting the
story right here because at a certain
point
I think this was actually before I got
out of my room at a certain point
this like sand
started seeping through the bottom of my
door
and coming up onto my bed and I was like
nah I'm not about this right now
definitely not about this right now
so that's why I go I go outside right
and I run to my mom who's wrapping
presents
and it's crazy because she doesn't even
acknowledge me she doesn't even know
that I'm there
and I remember the sand this pool of
sand
trickling out of my bedrooms like
seeping across the floor and it follows
me all the way to the living room where
I found my mom
wrapping presents
and
I climb up my mom she doesn't know I'm
there still
but I climb up my mom to get away from
the sand stuff
and dude so creepy the sand starts like
enveloping my mom
and like
climbing up to get me
and uh
it comes all the way up covers her face
and right before it touches me I'm like
perched on top of her head right before
it touches me I wake up and I had that
dream like
yeah like 30 times as a kid super creepy
to project
so I said I was gonna tell you about
three reoccurring dreams
the only three I've ever had that being
one of them that was the earliest one
the other two
was when I was living in Chino Hills we
moved to Chino Hills which is like 45
hour East outside of Los Angeles and I
lived there from 6 to 16 years old
and there we had a two-story house
um literally right up against the hills
of Chino right
so this recurring dream actually starts
dude that's so creepy all three
reoccurring dreams start the same way
where I wake up as if I was actually
awake in my bed
and um
the way our house was laid out is that
you I opened up my room opened up the
door
and basically went to like a uh
there was this half wall you know kind
of like a railing but it was like a
drywall and you can put your hand on it
like a little railing before you go down
the stairs it was kind of guiding you
down the stairs
and as you approach this wall
um you cut you have to kind of turn a
corner to go down the stairs right
so you can't see the stairs as you're
approaching them you have to turn the
corner and then go down
and I remember it being like three in
the morning and I come right up to the
wall there
and as I turn the corner this thing I
don't know what this thing just goes
right
at me
and it nearly gave me a heart attack
that happened like three or four times
um and then
the third recurring dream was the
weirdest one because it was like
actually I couldn't tell if it was real
or not
because I would wake up and hear a pack
of wild dogs just barking and running
down the hill
um and before I could like wait they
would wake me up and before I could go
look at them out the window
I would rush to the window and then they
would be gone
and this that happened like five times
I'm like what are the odds that
this pack of wild dogs
wakes me up five times
and isn't there every time I remember
too I'm like
oh I remember these dogs again I'm gonna
be quick
because they they escaped me every time
and they I never saw them I only heard
them so weird
thank you
so those are my
recurring dreams
that looks like everything right
let's give it some
oh maybe here we see ah but
probably wouldn't really okay let's add
the Shadows like we did
thank you
[Music]
awesome
let's go get these like
little edges of the straw here
Johnny Bosworth
my goodness the man the myth the legend
welcome
um dude you're just chilling eating
cement Oreos
that's what's up man those things are
pretty good
watching the CG Master hey but I I am no
CG Master because if you were here
earlier you see that I had some trouble
just beveling a simple old Edge and I
ain't even doing CG right now I'm up in
the Photoshop doing some drawing good to
see you man
um I was thinking of trying your hand at
a satisfying render in blender do it why
not it's super fun it's super fun JBoss
why don't you get up on the Discord and
join us for these weekly challenges you
don't have to do a full-on full month
one
a weekly will do you know and it's a
good way to a good way to hop in and
practice
good to see you dude
all right we're just doing some shading
here JBoss
and then we got one more
ring to do
animates
foreign
that's what the eraser's for we'll get
it
let's get that eraser at e
get up in there
looking good
sweet
freaking bucket problems dude rough
CG fiction also working on the challenge
with us
Good Times all around
okay
nice
looking good that's our second one
that's our first one the main one
now we got the final one
let's bring this guy up
[Music]
so wait
what else do we want to talk about okay
so I can talk about last weekend last
weekend was crazy
so last weekend
starting Friday at 7
00 P.M
[Music]
I did a 48 Hour film challenge 40 Hour
film race and it's the first time I did
it since 2008 I believe
and when I did that in 2008 first off
for you guys what is a 48 Hour film
challenge so basically you have to make
a short film
[Music]
in 48 hours you have to ride it you have
to come up with the idea you have to do
everything within 48 Hours nothing
pre-written none of that business
it's all just Fresh Off The Dome
[Music]
and you got 48 hours to do it so
last time I did it in 2008 I was living
in Georgia
and uh it came down to the last like
four minutes
last five minutes
and
the upload limit for some reason I you
know I spent I spent of course 40 hours
straight on this thing sleepless nights
absolutely brutal
and it came down to the last four
minutes like I'm saying here
and
the upload limit was for some reason 15
megabytes back in 2008 it was probably
one of those 15 megabyte upload limit
times you know we're like
people didn't have much storage space
these days or back in the day
so
my file at the last minute of upload as
I'm uploading this thing comes out as
15.1 megabytes
and dude I started Pride
so brutal
[Music]
I couldn't believe it I spent two
freaking whole days working on something
to upload it
submit it into this Film Festival this
challenge
and I come over
0.1 megabytes over the upload limit on
the final minute and I uh get
disqualified
so that was 2008
the next time I did that challenge was
last weekend
um and it uh it it was similar in a lot
of ways right so we have 48 hours
um working up to that week
um
of course I am trying to do my best to
build a team of people who will be able
to help
on those two days of shooting right
so I'm working with my buddy Jan who's
shooting it
um working with my wife Kim who's
helping write it
um
you know I got some actor friends
uh Christian was helping produce it
right so I was getting the The A Team
together as many people as I could find
and I'm doing all this about a week
before the actual Friday where this
thing goes live which was last Friday
right so
on Friday
around five o'clock everyone's gathered
at this studio uh Las Palmas Studio
in what is it in Sun on Sunset right
somewhere in LA right
and everyone's gathered there there's
159 teams participating in this film
challenge
40 Hour film challenge
and we draw our genres from a hat
is what we do right
and tell us this
um so we're drawing our genres from a
hat and we pull mockumentary slash
mystery so that means we can do either
mockumentary
or mystery or we could do both
and since we actually had an idea
for mockumentary and mystery kind of we
decided to do both and we were Off to
the Races we could have been more
excited about pulling that because man
um
we were ready we were ready by the time
they were still calling other teams to
pull up their genres we I was on the
phone uh with my wife
and we were writing and um you know Jan
was there we were writing and coming up
with a good good old time right
and once everyone had their genres
selected
they announced the three other thing the
three very very other important aspects
which are
the character you must include in your
short
prop that you must include and the line
of dialogue that must be included
and everyone it's the same for everybody
right so once everyone had all that
information we were Off to the Races
that's Friday at 7 pm okay last Friday
at 7 pm
dude we were up until 3 45 A.M
writing the script
and
it was so like it was fun don't get me
wrong it was super fun
but it was so crunchy that we basically
only had time to get a V1 script out
um
and
that was our shooting script at 3 45 in
the morning
and uh Christian he was like all right
guys this is it he set the script out to
everybody at 3 45 in the morning
and we show up the next day wake up at 5
45 get two hours of sleep and uh and we
take off to set which we're shooting at
my buddy Jan's place right
and we have like 12 people show up you
know got a nice crew I actually ended up
acting in the thing because we didn't
find we couldn't find uh another actor
we needed another actor so I had to step
in and act which was tough because I
hadn't well first off I have so many
things on my mind
um directing it right so it's like okay
you gotta make sure you get all the
stuff you need for the edit
um you got to focus on other actors
performances you got to make sure
everyone's doing their job right
um and has a task all this
and then oh oh yeah and I'm acting did I
memorize lines absolutely not
um so I'm in the hot seat and I'm like
trying to figure out this character
who's just a wild wacky character think
like Ben Stiller from dodgeball kind of
like that right here's what I'm going
for
um so it's it's wacky right
and
we shoot for 12 hours that day we shoot
for a full 12 hours
um
it was super fun really really fun
a lot of work but at this point I'm only
on two hours of sleep I come back to the
house with all the footage right
and I offload everything
my buddy Alec was putting the edit
together
and
he actually ends up staying at my place
until 6 A.M
while I get like six hours of sleep that
night because I knew I was gonna have to
wake up and continue the edit right
so
thank God for him he worked on that edit
through the morning
um and got me set up
continue the edit later that day but
when I woke up at 6am I was like dank
the edit just wasn't as far as it needed
to be and that's okay
no uh no hard feelings on out on Alec
there because it's tough what we
realized this is what I didn't realize I
did not know this
I did not realize how difficult it was
to to edit a documentary oh my God
even though it was scripted even though
we had lines there was a lot of like
riffing and and brains not brainstorming
but um
improv on set right a lot of that
so there was a lot of stuff that was off
book off script that needed to be sifted
through and put into the actual edit
to craft a story right
and you know I did not realize how hard
that was and how much time that would
take
so
kind of had to restart
and build it from scratch and that just
took so long I had sound designers I had
composers ready to go
but there was no edit for them to work
on
because the edit just wasn't ready it
took so long so long
so it got down to like you know delivery
is that day delivery is Sunday
at 7 pm 7 30.
and it's like Sunday at five and there's
not even a final edit and I'm like oh my
God
the last thing I can do here is not
deliver and waste everyone's time
who donated their time it's all it's all
free everyone donated their time to do
this
and if I'm coming out here and be like
hey guys I didn't make it I couldn't
have that could not have that
so
what do I do I keep crunching it's hairy
it's super stressful
um and I and I basically send my buddy
Adam
who's doing the music
I'm like dude
uh I know you're supposed to write
custom music for this but
can you just pull some like
stock music from the internet please and
put it in here because
I'm not gonna have time to do music and
it's a documentary it's a mockumentary
it needs music that's like the whole
thing
so he was doing that well I was still
trying to get the edit done and it has
to be under four minutes or sorry it has
to be over four minutes and under seven
minutes right
and when I put the full edit together yo
it wasn't even four minutes I was like
oh my God I only have so much time
like two hours or are left on this thing
so
the editing got a little uh not as tight
as I would have liked it was really tied
up towards the top it was feeling really
good up towards the top
not that I disliked it
because honestly at the end of the day
the freaking thing was hilarious
um I was really proud of all of us for
for pulling together and pulling off
that short
and I'd like to post it up here on my
Channel at some point
but
basically what happened in the last 30
minutes of this thing
was everything came together Adam sent
the music
Jan was sending over like the final
credits he was sending over a bunch of
like AI art still frames that I was
using to tell the story
um
and it all came together in the last
like 10 minutes
I didn't even have time to do a sound
mix I didn't have time to switch out any
music I didn't have time to polish
anything like literally what what was
exported was like the V 1.5
um and that's what we had to turn in
and that's what we had in 48 hours we
delivered two minutes and 30 seconds
before the deadline it was hairy my gun
it was so hairy
um
but we delivered so that was uh last
Sunday
not even a week ago
[Music]
but I learned a lot I really did and it
was really fun and I would do it again
so
I have plans on how to do it better next
time
[Music]
and uh yeah at the end of the day it was
a positive experience I really enjoyed
it
it was nice to just make something that
didn't have to be monetized it didn't
have to have a you know brand behind it
it didn't have to do well it was it just
had to be fun and that was the best part
so Monday
Monday I wake up and uh
I was just dead tired
we did our mod chat and then we did the
like the weekly Discord Meetup I was so
tired
I ended up going to the spa after that
just hitting the steam room getting a
massage
chilling out it was exactly what I
needed and then I got a massage the next
day too because I was so beat I was so
tired
and yeah it's a blender man it is a
public event they have them in every
city across the world it's called
48-hour film Project definitely check it
out it's super fun
um a great way for you and your friends
to get together and like make something
cool just for fun
I want to do more of them I'll
definitely be doing more of them
and I'm excited guys because we are
close
to seeing how this animates
all right
foreign
trying to think of any other stories I
can tell here
there was that time that
all of us at Corridor caught a robber
while we were eating pizza
that was pretty sweet
That's a classic one
um you guys may have heard that but I'll
tell it again it's a pretty short one so
basically we're eating at this place
called Pizza nista
um in in downtown L.A it's like between
the arts district and like the warehouse
District
and we're enjoying a a whole pizza we we
bought an entire pizza because it was
like six of us it was me Sam Nico Ren
Jake
um maybe Christian
and we're out there eating this pizza on
the corner of the street
and the next thing we know
we hear the sound of of glass breaking
like what the heck
Sam
basically points it out he's like hey
and he points at this dude who is
breaking into This Woman's car
um I mean she's not there we don't know
as a woman yet this is like after the
fact
he's breaking into this car and pulling
a bag out of the passenger seat
and
next thing I know like we're all just
chasing this dude
um he's on the opposite corner of the
street and we are chasing this dude and
at the time this was before we had like
all had one Wheels this was back in the
Razor scooter days
and we were all about the razor scooters
so we were we all had Razor scooters we
got on our Razor scooters and just
started
kicking after this they're just pedaling
hard after this guy
and he must have been like what the heck
does he look back
and he saw like six dudes on razor
scooters just like tearing towards him
and Nico
time thought it was a great idea
to like bring the pizza because dude
you're not just gonna leave the pizza so
he sees six dudes behind him coming
after him one of them is just holding a
large extra large pizza
so this dude takes off he's like no man
I'm not I'm not I'm not about to have
this
so he hops on his bike on his like BMX
bike
and Jake was like nah I'm not gonna do
the scooter
we're going on foot here Jake was a
track professional track and field Pro
so he takes off after this guy full
Sprint 100-yard dash
and the dude is like oh Jake starts
gaining on the guy
and he he chases him all the way down
the block until
the dude basically just Chucks his bag
in the hopes that like that will stop
Jake and he rounds the corner and takes
off to the east side and um
you know Jake didn't catch him I don't
know I don't know what would have
happened to Jake caught him I I don't
want to know
and uh
yeah I mean that we we called the we
call the the police security guard
pulled up
um
and there was nothing in the bag
he literally broke into her car just for
like gym clothes that was it
so uh put your bags in the trunk y'all
and um don't leave your pizza behind
all right I think we're at the point
here
where it's time to start exporting stuff
so what I'm gonna do
is
hit this with a white brush because I
want it to be
opaque
but you know what here uh yeah let's do
it here
let's do it here
dude it was some freaking Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles
[Music]
full opacity on this
I don't think it needs to be
super fancy
you know what I'm gonna do
I'm just gonna
mask it
just a rough mask
to see
if this actually works
oh
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's go and Export this as a PNG
I'm gonna bring this into after effects
[Music]
yo did I
no no
dude
I drew the same no
oh
it's gonna be all right it's gonna be
chill
oh
crap dude freaking crap
uh
I drew the same one twice
oh
End of Days
[Music]
no hold on now this is the center one
uh that's the center one
this is the
[Music]
uh-huh okay
this is technically the one I needed to
draw and didn't draw
crap
it's okay it's okay still chilling
let's work with what we got shall we
brutal dude
brutal
all right
yo I bet you I bet you guys
knew I was doing that too
and you're like you know what
let's just let it happen
I'm sure one of you guys were like
it's all good though
he's the drawing practice don't we
all right
this will still work though I'm still
glad
to be alive and drawing okay here we go
boom
town
all right and then let me save this out
as another PNG
that's gonna be our B
maybe we'll come back and we'll do the C
in a second but let's bring it in here
and let's see what the heck is going
down so let us
put assets
we got a
we got
B and it's B
is b a uh
PNG or is it not a PNG
I guess there's only one way to find out
that's to bring it up into our scene
okay yeah we're good we're good we're
good
um what's the best way
honestly
I think I need to like render let's see
let's render this without the people
background test
let's get rid of our
all of this let's get rid of
the ring
and it's literally just our background
scrolling which I know I can definitely
do
side of After Effects but
I'm gonna just do it this way right now
because uh
you know
it's called BG
render
V1 great
and um let's go ahead and save this
put in assets
background render V1
go for it
maybe while this does its thing
and it's probably the the most
ridiculous way to be rendering a
background let's try and beat the render
and just do this again here in Photoshop
one more time
and then we're gonna figure out how this
goes and boy am I not gonna mess this up
again I promise this is definitely the
one we need to do
confirmed
I promise
all right
thank you
[Music]
foreign
for One More Story then huh
see
good stories oh my God okay there's a
couple
there's the track story I'll tell you
the track Story the track story is a
rough one for me
um a handful of times in my life I've
been publicly embarrassed
bad like bad and this is one of those
times
so the track story I am in high school
[Music]
um maybe 11th grade
and we have a home track meet
one second let me pour this tea
[Music]
we have a home track meet
and
it's a night meat so it's it's a cold
one
freezing cold
um this is in Georgia
there's like a farm next to the chicken
farm next door and like that chicken poo
is just wafting over the hills uh it's
smelling fierce
and I have uh three events three events
two of which are important
first event is the pole vault right and
that's first up a track meet is hours
long hours long okay lots of events lots
of people
and uh
tovo comes first I knocked that out
super solid you know whatever
I got like two hours before I do hurdles
okay
so I'm like this is Peak like
um DS Nintendo DS ERA with the game
shark which basically gets you all the
rare Pokemon
so we all got our DS's we all got
Pokemon and one of our friends has a
game shark so we're like let's get them
Pokemon you know what I'm saying
so we're like all right let's hit the
middle of the field
little friend Circle going
game shark passing around game shark for
hours having a blast
and we're in sweats because it's
freezing outside
and the next thing I know
I hear
oh God
I hear over the intercom
Clinton Jones get to the starting line
now
and I was like oh my God and it was my
coach and dude he was so freaking pissed
ah
my heart sank
because I look over
and there's everyone at the Block at the
starting block
in like runner's pose ready to go ready
to run hurdles and I'm like oh my God
there's only been
twice two times in my life that I can
think
that I was that stressed out like panic
attack
so I do what any
dude would do I you know basically uh
start taking off my sweats as fast as I
can
and head over to the starting line and
as I'm doing this I'm rushing so fast
that I pull everything off everything
down to my little
naked little body
and I basically flash all the dudes in
front of me
they go down
and I hear someone who's like practicing
pole vault
on the other side of the field I hear
him scream he he goes down
and I and and I hear hundreds of people
in the stands
to my right and behind me I just hear
this wave of oh
and
oh man
um
it was bad guys it was really bad
so I had no time to react I'm like dude
I just flashed everyone hundreds of
people everyone in in the track meet all
the parents all the kids
in the stands
um and I have no choice but to just pull
up my pants and run to the starting line
so
so um
I make it to the starting line keep in
mind I am like not warmed up guys is a
cold night
and I'm already starting to cramp
because the run over was not was not uh
not helpful
I make it to the starting line
absolutely mortified I looked at the
dude next to me and I'm like yo
did you see that
and he was like
no
I was like okay thank God someone didn't
see it
I'm clear
eyes on the prize let's run this race
dude let's freaking run this race
um I'm pretty good at hurdles I got the
technique down
so
um the starting gun goes off and and
here we go we're off right I hop one
hurdle there's ten of them by the way I
hop one I hop two I hop three
and the third one I clip like I clip it
pretty hard oh
um not being warmed up is starting to
catch up with me
and so is everyone else they start
passing me like it's nothing
um
fourth hurdle clip that one fifth one
clip that one sixth one seventh one
eighth one by this time
I'm in last place and I'm clipping every
hurdle there is dude
and by the time I get over the last
hurdle
um I'm in last place of course
everyone's crossed the finish line and
because I'm not warmed up
my body just freezes up shuts down
and I straight up just trip
over the finish line
dive roll over the finish line
and that was probably one of the most
embarrassing moments of my life
it's bad
that was bad
so that's the track story
um
there's some other ones
that's a longer one though maybe that's
one for another stream what are some
other embarrassing moments
that's brutal
and there's the time I almost died rock
climbing I guess
this was when
me and my buddy cliff
of course my rock climbing buddy would
be named cliff right
um
this is when we weren't as smart and we
were all about just having a good old
time right
and we go out to Joshua Tree
which is a very popular famous rock
climbing spot in Southern California we
go out to Jay tree
and
we don't have ropes at the time we're
just bouldering bouldering is when you
climb just 10 feet without ropes and you
have a little Crash Pad it's not a big
deal it's a good old time right
and um
we go out there
and let me just try and make sense of
this okay yeah there we go we go out
there
it's me my buddy Casey and cliff
and we take the day we start climbing
just bouldering climbing around again no
ropes
very doable stuff we're not climbing
High we're not doing anything like that
and we see we see this woman like
do this no rope climb on some crazy
climb you're like whoa it looks doable
let's try it so we start it we get about
halfway through this climb which is like
you're basically
traversing which is like uh scrambling
um
laterally we're moving laterally across
this Lake three two to three inch little
like
Cliff little divot and below us is just
this drop and we get halfway out the
wall and we look back or we look up
which is when the climb starts and we're
like dude this is so sketchy
let's not do this so we back out of it
and we're just blown away the at the
fact that like she could do that
without ropes I'm like dang that's crazy
so we continue about our day
and
we see another climb
kind of looks doable it's this big old
crack in the wall it goes up right big
old thing like this and in this there's
this crack inside of it that we're able
to kind of like put our bodies into as
we climb up
and um we start climbing that crack and
we do it for a while
and it's a blast it's doable it's safe
there's no chance of us like slipping or
falling because we're kind of in this
crack right but at a certain point the
crack starts to like
Elevate and it starts to get steeper and
steeper right
climbing this thing
and
um we start passing bolts which I didn't
know I should I think I knew at the time
what that meant
now I really know what that means it's
basically it's a rope climb it's a climb
that uh you're gonna be clipping in for
safety
so we're passing these little safety
bolts and I'm like huh that's
that's odd
and um
stupid me I kept climbing I kept
climbing and uh
we get to the point where like it's
pretty vertical
and it's like we're up we are up there
and if we fall it's probably not gonna
be too hot but we're still pretty
confident that like we're not gonna fall
it's just one of those climbs we feel
confident enough on it right we've been
climbing a lot
and
but then but we keep going we keep going
and we get like two moves from the top
where Cliff is like literally below me I
have to like look down
to to see him
and we're kind of stuck at this point
and we realized we realize here
that it was all chill up until now
because he says to me hey man my foot is
going to give out it's shaking really
hard
you either need to keep like you need to
keep going because I need to get a
better foothold
and I'm one move from the top like
thinking now uh
I I would have a hard time going back
down
so let's see what this top is like I
guess so I this is so dumb I go for the
next move which now is the I'm at the
last move
and I'm sitting here like I have two
choices
I can either
and we're like asking like we turn back
to my buddy Casey who's watching this
and he's so far away at this point we're
like it caught up with us real quick and
we look back and we're like okay
do I have a
foot and we're like oh that's not a good
sign
um
so I I have two choices now I can either
I can't reach the top
I'm reaching on my on my tippy toes
trying to reach for the top hole a
secure hold
and I got nothing it's just a slope that
goes like this and that's all I have I
would literally would have would have
had to jump not knowing what I'm
reaching for and hope that something is
grabbable up there and Cliff is like a
handful of inches shorter than me so who
knows if he would have been able to do
that I'm maxed out
my other option is to turn around
um in my head I'm like look if I do that
if I jump and best case scenario I grab
something
we're not getting down like we'd have to
be airlifted away
or have someone call for help and have
some climber like lower us
so in that moment I'm like dude we got
it we gotta go down we gotta head back
down
so dumb like I wish I would have said
that sooner
and um
we're both just Knuckleheads man we've
gotten into this situation twice one
time was not enough
but it takes us like 30 minutes to get
back down but it was sketchy because if
we would have fallen
yeah it would have been it would have
been really bad it would have been
really really bad
so that was the rock climbing story and
I think we're done yay
um let's shade this thing and let's
bring it into after effects
[Music]
all right
y
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
sweet all right I think we're good
just gonna mask it out and then let's
see how it animates
I'm excited
oh
my God
foreign
Sweet let's bring in that c the let's
bring in that render of the background
and let me turn off Windows ink
finally
[Music]
be gone
oh free
let's make a new
project here
sweet this is our animated background
and then let's uh let's bring in the
render for reference because this will
be
kind of what we use to line up the ring
with
[Music]
all right
so we got a B and C
[Music]
and we have to choose like when they
snap on
and off
so let's let's see here
um
great we got all three
and I'll put them
let's see let's how are we gonna do this
I'll just line it up
all of them in the middle
[Music]
mm-hmm right so we'll go from one to the
other
starting with that one
going to this one and ending on this one
okay
all right so it kind of has like a 3D
3D spin to it
awesome so it's going to kind of start
like that we'll have
some time with that one
this one will be
on the tail end so it's basically just
reversed
or symmetrical
right
boom and then it goes out
spins in spins out
Let's uh figure out how many frames we
need of each
piece
start with two
and I'm just guessing here take these
two
bring them to the end
and stretch this out over time and
ideally all we need to do really is uh
select all these pre-compose it with
Ctrl shift C and that just puts it into
a folder essentially you can also go
layer pre-compose
we'll call this
technically it's the ring it just has
its own fancy name
and I'm going to animate this
our render right so
let's just go ahead and hit t for
opacity drop it to 50.
and we'll start with it scoot it over
here
P for position
and I'll go to the last frame
we'll move it over
to match
and we'll find this uh let's see
[Music]
foreign
basically once it hits here let's go
ahead and remove it
boom
and then
once it hits here
kind of get this over here
and then it starts to take off
let's just see what this looks like
a little rough
and a little hard to see to be honest
[Music]
so I feel like this maybe I probably
need like two more or one more for uh
for this kind of 3D look
to get that look right
[Music]
alternatively like
I might be able to break these up and
actually
kind of slide them around as 3D objects
and kind of fake that 3D look a little
bit I could use this in like shorten up
this Edge or something
[Music]
I could also go in here and add a little
bit more
these guys
[Music]
foreign
It's Tricky yeah so this is this is
technically my first test here of a 3D
3D animated something
um
I think what I need is
projecting it might be the move actually
I wonder how far that will take me
let's give it a shot and then I'm
probably gonna call it for today
let's also see if I know how to project
stuff off the top of my head
so that's the
this is the one we want
cool
projected onto there
we did frame 46 so if our camera
[Music]
um
how's this gonna work
we need to bring in that layer as
texture
um so let's go ahead and set that up
open this guy up grab out the diffuse
image texture
[Music]
and we'll grab that centered one
we want the alpha
and for the camera we want
projection let's see
[Music]
let me try a thing in a new project file
just to test out a stuff
we want to project it onto this Cube
[Music]
what the heck why
all right so I dropped this onto the
cube
and it's gonna look like
nothing
there we go okay
[Music]
so projection how does this work again
this
goes on yeah okay this changes to
[Music]
camera mapping and then we select
this camera
depending on yeah there it is depending
on like where
is
we see it down there all right
I think that comes down to can I move
can I offset this
okay all right so in here what we'll do
let's render that
us
actually let's come into Photoshop
[Music]
or rather what we can do is actually
just import this because I want to make
sure the aspect ratio is correct
[Music]
technically this needs to be
38 40 by 16 20.
there we go so that's our actual size
now
um
but let me do a test let me do a test
so we have
this guy let's
drag this out
make sure this is set up properly this
needs to be normal
get this to opacity
and Alpha
awesome
so if we render this
that doesn't look good because we need
to set it to projection
camera mapping and select our camera
and that still doesn't work
if we move it up the offset
or down rather
see it's in there I see it in there
but maybe I need to tile it
I don't know how to match it exactly
we can go to this UV mode
and I see it in there
it's not moving because I think it is
set to camera projection
um if I set it to
one
um
foreign
[Music]
getting it to line up exactly is is
actually kind of tricky I don't know
best way to go about that
yeah I don't know
that's definitely some r d that I have
to get into
tricky indeed tricky indeed y'all
um so I think uh
foreign
I think that's it you know
um
I've learned a lot here uh I have some
some things to research
in order to get this look correct and to
to have it work out maybe I just need to
make more frames maybe I need to figure
out projection mapping a little bit more
um
yeah I need some in-between frames and I
wonder if I could do it with like EV
synth or something
to make the in-between frames because
I'd be here until next Christmas
doing all these frames
um so
yeah it's giving me something to think
about here it was fun I had a good time
drawing and that again that's the whole
point of this I want to change up the
style because doing new Styles is fun
um
but yeah yeah lots to get into the week
is basically my time to research and the
the streams are my time to execute that
research and kind of catch you guys up
on where I'm at so
I appreciate you guys for uh for hanging
out with me and for uh hanging out
during story time I didn't know it was
gonna be story time but absolutely
all right let's read your comments a
little bit here I'll hang up with you
guys for the next five minutes or so
five or ten
um visual says you do the 3D first
export the viewport then draw on top and
then reproject
you do the 3D first export the viewport
and then draw on top
and then reproject I basically did that
though
I base it I feel like I basically did
that
um you should have the animation on like
an old scroll or piece of paper almost
like it's telling a really old story
that's fun
um
and all good you know we all blue screen
from time to time but thanks for joining
me man I appreciate you
can I publish my intuo settings on
Discord
um sure
yeah I can do that I can do that I'll
put them in the uh
what channel will be best for that
Hardware yeah okay I'll do it in
Hardware
I'll put it in the hardware uh section
let's see any of the questions you you
guys have
beer for the next five or ten
am I a self-taught artist
yeah as as in I Didn't I went to a year
and a half of tech school
digital media arts was the degree but I
dropped out to come back out here to
California to make some shorts with
Freddie and pursue filmmaking so
um
yeah just YouTube tutorials and and
doing it just having fun that's how I
learned
it's the way a lot of us learn these
days
um
see
[Music]
okay he says I said switch the last two
animation frames
looks like it rotates in the wrong
direction as it is now
does it
oh yeah I need to mirror it
yeah I need to I need to mirror it
that's that's the issue thank you
appreciate it
[Music]
Chris
oh the Mary has great 2D and character
animator tutorials thank you I'm gonna
take that down I could use all the help
I can get
appreciate it yeah that's good stuff
oh wow you're watching bghs that's crazy
yeah that's old well not it's not old
old show but it was a show that Freddy
um and and Matt and will did back at
Rocket Jump back in those days kind of
before writer's Corridor was starting
um video game high school yeah good
times
what's my process when I write short
films
um so for okay I'll use this 40 Hour
film festival or this film Project as an
example
we had 48 hours to do this and we had to
write the short on Friday night so that
we filmed it on Saturday so we did not
have a lot of time so what we did was
essentially we had an idea in mind
because we're basically brainstorming
all the way up until this challenge
um and trying to have ideas in back in
our back pocket
and luckily we did so what we did was
laid out the idea kind of talked out the
idea made all these ideas
um in our head of like what would go
into the project all these moments but
they weren't in any sort of order
and what we did is actually we used like
little note cards here
and I would just rip a note card write
down one of the moments and lay it on
the ground and I did that for every
moment we had and then I wrote like a
few note cards for the order like um
you know if you're doing a short or a
movie it'd be act one act two act three
um but in this case it was like uh intro
to the world
uh set up the main character
interview other people like con the
controversial side because we did a we
did a um a mockumentary so we had
interviews where like this character
um there was like conspiracy theories as
to what happened to their disappearance
so there's like the controversial uh
conspiracy theory section and then it
was the the ending so we basically
blocked it out in note cards and we
ordered them all around oh this would be
better here's to be better here and then
once you had the order of it then we
kind of we wrote it out in detail so
that was literally a block out a sketch
um it's called an outline so we did that
and uh yeah then you just write you
write from there you make those little
beats more detailed uh just as you would
a 3D render same thing
oh thank you
um Seiler I will update that thank you
so much
yep
so the submission link is live
[Music]
um and it's in a part of it says endless
engines
I'll switch that to boss fight
do I have any tips on animating in slow
motion
when I animated a higher frame per
second and slow it down to where I want
um
well
I think it depends on how you're doing
it if you're choosing your keyframes and
you're blending between those keyframes
you may not have to do every single
frame
if you're trying to slow down say like
any of the motion capture files yes it's
helpful I have the higher frame rate
version that you can use that slowed
down so it really depends and also also
like I'm not the best animator so I'm
sure some will have some better advice
for you on that
when do you get to see the short film I
don't know but I would love to post it
up on my channel
um when I post some random oh what up
Casey
what up son
what's going on
Casey the composer for Endless engines
in the house what up dude
all right guys I'm at the bounce here
I'm gonna get some food before I pass
out
y'all much appreciated thank you for
stopping by
um it's been fun working on our art
together
so
um a couple things just to wrap up we
have boss fight stickers you can grab
them Link in the description it's a
whole sticker sheet they're super cool
design my my buddy Gabe peregrino
um so grab yourself one for the
challenge collect a little challenge
slope swag
um the submission link is live that's
also in the description you don't need
to submit just because there's a link
take your time with your art
um use all the time you got
uh what else what else
um Monday
I will be on the Discord server in our
little uh weekly Meetup that we do
to be myself and the moderators just
chatting with you guys specifically I
know that we're on a live stream right
now but I can't really talk with you
guys because it's just all in chat but
on the Discord server on Monday at noon
PST
um
you guys will actually come up on the
stage we can have a little back and
forth about your render about your art
see where you're at uh talk about any
problems
um or just look at your cool art in your
look at your work in progress so that'll
be this upcoming Monday all right and
we'll have an event on the on Discord
side of things as well so
guys
much appreciated thank you so much
I'll catch you all soon peace out y'all
later
[Music]